our society is really
totally nuts fauci wrote and emails now
made public usa today's story emails
sent by dr anthony fauci
in the early days of the pen they make
reflect the thoughts of a patient but
weary man who was
flabbergasted by his overnight celebrity
hundreds of emails were obtained by the
washington post and other uh
organizations through
freedom of information acts request
falchi responds to hundreds of
interrogators
many he doesn't know often in in-depth
answers fauci also corresponded on
multiple occasions
with george gawa top infectious disease
official in china gao sent an
uh encouraging note when fauci was being
blasted by trump supporters who blamed
him for supporting social distancing
rules that closed
schools tanked the economy and
threatened trump's re-election prospects
thank you for your kind note voucher
replied three days later
all is well despite some crazy people in
this world fauci marveled
at an april 2020 story titled cuomo
crush
and fouchy fever sexual sexualization of
these men is a real thing
on the internet fauci forwarded the
email to someone whose identity was
redacted
urging the person to click on the link
it would blow your mind fauchi wrote our
society is really
totally nuts it continues not the story
by business insider
a leading scientist said the world needs
to understand the origins of covet 19 to
prevent kobe 19.
uh okay this goes into a different email
i'll stop right here go with the email
so tell me fouchy emails what are your
thoughts gerard you can go first try to
hold it together by the way
man bro first of all whoever wrote that
glowing review
i was watching cnn last night because i
hate myself and
i they were like this man those emails
showcased the
the one the one honest man in a
dishonest organization i was like you
i'm i i'm gonna say stuff that's gonna
get you kicked off youtube bro i gotta
calm it down for just a second dude
i got kicked off of facebook i got
kicked off i got demonetized 120 000
plus followers
i built this thing over years national
tours i had all my videos i was selling
my tours
and facebook i woke up one day and they
just said that's it
you have restricted access uh restricted
reach
my videos used to like i used to put out
a video and then i had a bad no matter
how bad the video was i can count on 100
000 views fine whatever now i put out a
video if i get 10 000 views it's a good
video
right like i had 15 videos get over a
million views now if i get a video gets
over 10 000 it's a big big thing
facebook just turned me off they turned
the spigot off and the money i made went
away
and you know what i did for them to do
that i shared an article
from the xcdc director who said
that it's very likely that this disease
came from
the wuhan lab now i had been skeptical
in fairness i had been skeptical of
everything i had been told
from the beginning i was very very very
cautious when this first happened
but then after two months it really took
me two months to be like man there's
something real weird about this
was everything that they described that
there's you know
anybody who if you don't wear a mask if
you're if you're in a closed air
circuited area if you're not wearing
gloves
you know this your extreme danger my
first thought was
growing up in new york man i'm like yo
the homeless are dead there's going to
be homeless piling up in the streets
this is going to be a nightmare my god
these people sleep on the subways on top
of each other
they live in squalor they eat food out
of the garbage these people are going to
be dead
and then when they warrant and everybody
was was inside and it was like
you know the homeless came out like deer
in the middle of the night and then i'm
like then these people are fine
something's not being told and then they
started with this mask and the mask
stuff
as if this was like a hazmat suit and
now i've worked construction
anybody who's ever dry walled anybody
who's ever sanded in one of those masks
knows when they take that mask off and
their mouth is completely full of
particles
that that's bs anybody who's ever farted
through underwear and jeans and still
smelt it
knows it's bs the the fabric isn't doing
nothing if you're smelling that methane
then a virus can get through that mask
they placeboed us
and you're looking at this emails and
they're trying to cover this stuff up as
if oh well you know he
he told the match because we didn't have
enough mass no that's not
the story what's interesting about this
gerard here's what's interesting about
the story
uh it's interesting because just a week
and a half ago he said it could be
man-made
then the emails were released so why
did he say a week and a half ago it
could be man-made then the emails were
wrong
freedom of information did he did he say
it could be man-made before the emails
being released because he
wanted to make sure he said that he was
written did you see what the very first
email he sent was
which one this was in january 31st okay
this this man
doesn't just need jail he needs to be
expatriated
we need to slingshot this dude over to
beijing they can have this much comment
the first thing that he did was he found
out
that it would that this virus the one
percent of it is going to show that it
was man-made and the first thing he did
is call his assistant and call his major
donor and make sure that we are not
doing gain of function research in wuhan
anymore right that was the first thing
that he did
and then he goes for months and months
and months acting like he doesn't know
what this virus is and where it came
from
when it was the nih his place that that
that paid for the research at the lab
for this gain of function
the very first question he asked was is
it gain of function then he goes before
the senate
and rand paul specifically asked him
rampo who's a doctor
mind you he's a doctor not a lawyer a
doctor he asked him he's like
are you doing gain of function no i'm
not doing gain of function is this guy
who you're in contact to doing gain of
function and fouchy does that that that
smirk that
if he does gain a function he's doing it
within the rule dude
he knew from the get he knew from the
jump
exactly what this was and exactly what
it meant
and he lied to us from the beginning
this man needs to be
this man needs to be expatriated this
guy stole
two years of our lives two years of our
lives he stole it
and i thought i didn't like fouchy no
um you know what candice owens says that
he should go to prison i mean that's a
pretty strong statement you know here's
my thing
anybody that is out there and that is
intuitive you saw what i saw
and here's the first thing i saw about
falsely he's a weasel
okay that's the first thing i thought
the flip-flopping he's he's weak
he's affected and it just comes across
in
all his press conferences he's the
highest paid employee like we've talked
about there needs to be a federal
investigation into this this is serious
i mean if china got away with this and
he's and he's having emails with them
saying we're going to get through this
together
i mean he's literally saying this like
they're our ally he just doesn't get it
and i'm saying his age is a factor he's
80 years old
he's 30 years past his prime he needed
to go a long time ago
but here and you know this is going to
sound funny and like i'm making fun of
it but he literally
has one function he is the mascot of the
corona virus
they put him in front of it like a
little dancing clown and he's the little
happy
cherubic little this guy right here that
is fauci he is the mascot for the
coronavirus
cheerleader wear your mask don't wear
your master you know i even invented the
foundation
should i show them the fouchy dance pat
you want to see this
this is the fouchy dance
[Laughter]
that is the fact it's right there moves
buddy that's so impressive you know he
should be like the uh
phoenix suns gorilla and every philly
fanatic he should go to disneyland
you talk about mascots and you talk
about theater tom every every jerk on
twitter every single person in brooklyn
jersey that's
that was every karen that was screaming
trust the science
trust the science trust the science
there you go
this is it trust your science you
blindly these people in this freaking
obedience cut
a cult who who who blindly trust the
science
this is what you get this is the science
that you blindly trusted
and you bullied everybody into trusting
as well this is nonsense and he deserves
to be held accountable
and jail is not too far my whole point
is he's not cut out for this position he
should have been gone a long time
i don't know inspired everybody let me
let me tell you how
uh let me tell you how uh loyalty is
created loyalty is created during
tough times and how you treat somebody
during tough times right meaning
when everything is good it's like ah
yeah everything's good and then all of a
sudden somebody's going through some
survey like hey man you know distance
yourself from that individual right
okay where am i going with this just a
year ago
who was the next democratic presidential
leading candidate uh in america a year
ago cuomo cuomo
he was the biggest celebrity his book
deal made him five
billion dollars he won an emmy every
day we heard cuomo right what happened
three four months ago all of a sudden
all of a sudden three four months ago
stories started coming out where
schumer didn't like him you know not
didn't like him they wanted the all the
stories with me too movement
you know you had the other women coming
out of this aoc
everybody all of a sudden distanced
themselves from who well it turned out
his policies ended up killing more
people than say
well sure but i mean you're right but
there's a big difference between a
cuomo and a fouchy here's where i'm
going with this here's
what could potentially happen with fauci
fauci
within the next six months if any of
these stories
get the kind of credibility that they
get and create momentum
watch how quickly everybody
on the left is going to turn against
this guy watch how
quickly this guy's going to be in on an
island all by himself
here's here's what you have to think go
go to fauci
in his bedroom it's 11 30 he's sleeping
at night do you think he stays up that
late that
uh 100 i think right now he is imagine
it's 11 o'clock at night
and he's sitting in his office or he's
done watching the news by himself wife
everybody's asleep he's by himself right
what's he thinking right now
who's he talking to right now he's
feeling the chronic who's he feeling
supports him right now who has his back
right now is he sitting there saying
uh the media has his back right now
maybe is he sitting there saying
you know uh biden pelosi those guys have
his back right now
i don't know is he sitting there saying
china has us back
nih has his back cdc has his back who
bill gates how many emails
how many bill gates zuckerberg what are
you doing communicating with zuckerberg
bill gates who has us back right now
who is backing him up right now look
how many things were considered a
conspiracy theory let's go through one
it was what it was
man-made that was one of them right that
was one of the things that
that was that was a conspiracy theory
but a chinese guy eating a pangolin
wasn't
we were supposed to buy that but that's
one the other one was hydroxy
chlorine uh uh quinn was what no it
doesn't work
right so a part of the email maybe
gives a hint that maybe it does work
right hey maybe it does have
some kind of positive effects you know
face masks don't work they do work
double masking it doesn't work it does
work okay
we have to figure that out lockdown was
necessary was it necessary do we really
need to do a lockdown
closing the schools yeah your schooling
all of this stuff that you sit there and
you look at
those things have to be investigated
simple as that they have to be messing
with answers but i will
tell you like this he will be dropped
like this it will be remember comey
was a hero he went up there and he's
doing this he's doing that he's doing
this and then the one time right before
the election comey said what
there's very likelihood that hillary
clinton's emails and then he
flipped he flipped and then that hurt
hillary's election chances
i don't know if you remember this or not
it was right before the election comey
was their hero well we have to listen to
him because he is the fbi director you
know we have to listen to what he has to
say
then the moment he flipped all of a
sudden where's his credibility
who is he well he this is not fair he
shouldn't be saying these kinds of
things two weeks before the election
fauci comey similar camps
different areas of the camp and like
this
he'll be all by himself on an island my
sister within probably a couple weeks
i think it's going to go quick and i
think if you all of a sudden start
seeing additional stories
stories that could go back to aids
stories that could go back 40 years
stories that
go back to women stories that could go
back the degree he got stories that
could go back he was never really a
valedictorian so just
nonsense stories like that could come
out you already kind of know what's
going to happen right after that go
ahead my
family are democrats my sister in
particular is a pretty staunch democrat
right and um
this was my message to her because she's
actually to speaking
of if anything good has come out of the
last two years
they're a little more open to getting
off that left hard line they're a little
more open to taking in some new
information okay
and and as a libertarian i've i've been
ripping republicans for years
and i was i i marched against bush and
cheney in college i i was
anti-war i was i still am anti-blood for
for oil and then i i said i told her i
was like bush and cheney are stumping
for biden now
that should be paused for reflection for
you okay and it was
in fairness to her it was one thing to
take away from this and it's a very good
point you just made patrick is that
they're dumping these guys because they
are liars
we are in the age of accountability like
i said before democrats if you're
listening to this okay
you are america's gas pedal republicans
are america's break
we need both the gas pedal we need both
the break we need you
just as as much as we we need desantis
but we need you to stop
giving your side a break you give these
people
a free pass all the time there is never
any accountability in your camp please
for the love of all that is holy if you
are listening to this
stop with the hero worship stop with the
cult of personality
dump these people dump them if they're
wrong they're wrong
bill maher to his credit who i disagree
with politically
he has already jumped off the fouchy
bandwagon it's been a month already
guys if they are wrong they bankrupted
your neighbor
they convinced you that everybody that
you interacted with was a threat to your
health
they convinced you to view your fellow
man as a threat
they put people they locked people in
their homes bankrupted them
killed them how many people with
addiction how many people with
with with anxiety suicidal thoughts that
they locked in a room
to serve their political ambitions guys
you've got to hold these people
accountable this can't be a trial
i mean here's what's going to happen the
the i i think
as we age we reason better and hope i
bank
on a small percentage of people to say
hey what the hell is really going on
i'm getting a lot of people right now
that are contacting me saying look
uh i'm i'm a republican who questioned
trump i'm a democrat who questioned my
side there's a lot of weird things going
on right now i just
much rather find out exactly what's
going on i just want the truth
not everybody wants to true gerard you
have to realize there's a lot of people
that don't want to there's a lot of
people that would much rather just live
a regular life don't tell me everything
that's going on
let me just go about myself there's a
very small community of people that are
actually going to adjust
very small the percentage is not as big
as you think it's a five to ten percent
it's a small margin of people that are
going to sit there and say
you know what you're right i'm going to
go investigate a little bit more let's
see what's going to be taking place
and i think the next three six months
believe it or not i think things are
going to move very
very quickly and we will learn a lot
about what happened
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye